Let's go to Hawaii from D.C. first.
Harvey from D.C., you're on the air.
Oh, David, can you hear me? Yes, I can. Yes. And
make my own voice is echoing back. So ideally,
you would be maybe listening and headphones are
turning down your speakers. All right. I was
just in a certain class action. Let me try to fix
that while we're interrupting class. That's wild.
OK, is that better? It is.
OK, so I was wondering, do you think that
there's that the Republicans are going to have
their own version of Bill Clinton in a sense that
due to, I guess, branding issues, they're going to
want to have a candidate that use them to the left
the same way that Bill Clinton for the Democrats
to the right, like a Republican that says, you
know what, Obamacare is the free market solution
to health care. You know what? We're going to
legalize drugs and try to center all those.
You know, now it's kind of a centrist policy,
but I think there's a market for progressive
policies, but finding the right direction.
Do you think that that's something that's
going to happen or some of this possible?
Well, you know, I'm not so sure that I understand
that by today's standards, Bill Clinton is no
progressive. But I'd have to think more about
whether in 1992, Bill Clinton moved the Democratic
Party to the right. Is that is that what you're
saying as part of your premise that in 92,
Clinton was a rightward move for the Democratic
Party? That's what that's a while ago.
That's true in any case, I mean, I think that
there's more to explore there, but let me focus
on your main question. I think the answer is
it's too early to know and it really comes down
to do Republicans learn anything from the Trump
fiasco? How will we be able to tell? Well, we'll
be able to tell when we look at like do Marjorie
Taylor Greene, Lauren Bobber and Madison Cawthorn,
do they end up being one term wonders and
immediately voted out in twenty twenty two, or
do they get second terms? That would be a signal
about what the Republican Party thinks it needs at
this point in time. Does Sarah Huckabee, Sanders
riding on being Trump's former press secretary,
win the gubernatorial
Republican primary in Arkansas?
Do Ivonka or Larra Trump or any of them
run successfully for something? I think
we don't yet know what the Republican
Party will think it needs to do.
Well, then let me let me entertain
this, do you think that there's
and I see this a little bit with Joe Scarborough
talking about Medicare for all other telcos.
You talk about that and how he his
rationale is that it actually is
a set of policies that maximizes free to maximize
individualism, maximize entrepreneurship.
So you said it's a progressive policy
within a sort of right wing direction.
You can see that with like marijuana people
that are pushing for legalizing drugs. Yep.
It's it is the more liberty oriented,
quote unquote, position. I was wondering,
do you think that there is the possibility that.
Candidates that have, I guess, that viewpoint of,
hey, I'm not doing things just I'm not
doing things just because I guess like the
donor class or like beliefs that are
entwined with politicians want something.
I'm doing these things because when they're good
for people and that's the whole question of how
you craft a society. And then two, it actually
fits within conservative ideology of like,
you know, I value markets, I value individuals,
my value family, and taking these ideas that
are progressive and then maybe having more
still like a free market approach to that.
So this is this is not a new idea with this is
the idea of appealing to your typical political
opponents by framing your positions in ways that
appeal to their values. And you and I aren't going
to be able to figure out whether that is or isn't
a good idea today. There's a lot of scholarship
on you should like for example, you're making a
perfect, perfect case here. The liberty argument
with something like cannabis, even if that's not
the reason why the left supports legalization,
we can appeal to the right by you by framing
it as an issue that appeals to their values.
The first question is whether that's effective.
And there's a lot of debate about that. The second
question is whether the problem with it is that a
lot of modern conservatism is not really motivated
by liberty. They claim to be, but they really
aren't. They're actually very authoritarian.
And as George Lakoff writes, they subscribe to
something called strict father morality, which is
if you do something bad, your dad has to punish
you for it, even if you can justify it in some
way. And so I would want to think more about that.
I'm not so sure. But anyway, David.
I actually heard about strict father, I forgot
the third word, but like the strict father,
kind of like political theory or
whatever through here in your Joe Rogan.
So thank you for putting me on that. That
was really interesting. But I'm going to let
you go. But I do want to thank you one last
time, because this time last year, I was in
a government class with a teacher that didn't
teach very much. And I was also voting for the
first time. And your channel and other channels
kind of helped me understand issues and beautiful
discover different policies and some political
philosophy. So thank you for that, David.
Thank you. I really appreciate it. And I
hope to to speak to you again. Very well said